[Musique]
oui ces milices au mans lundi puis
bienvenue à paroles autochtone alors
cette semaine je pense que je peux peut
m'échapper du sujet des élections
d
je pense c'est la seule chose qu'ils
tenteraient d'inonder toutes mes médias
sociaux c'est les élections le débat des
chefs
les sujets qui sont à l'ordre du jour
est ce que je voudrais partager avec
vous ces deux choses que je trouve quand
même assez encourageant la première
c'est que sur chacune des plateformes
électorales maintenant il y a un aspect
autochtone je pense que j'en ai pas raté
une alors que par le passé beaucoup
beaucoup de parties avaient des fois la
tendance à faire une plateforme à ces
minuscules ou carrément inexistante pour
parler des enjeux autochtones donc ça je
peux donner crédit que la mobilisation
des communautés a fait qu on se rend
compte que la voix des communautés
compte énormément et quand je parle de
la voix des communautés je parle aussi
d'un enjeu de discussions extrêmement
important c'est à dire le vote parce que
je vous en ai souvent parlé par le passé
le vote et communaux des docks tonnes
est pas toujours une chose qui est
garanti premièrement de façon
idéologique
beaucoup de gens des communautés
refusent de voter parce que ce vote
pourrait vouloir dire qu'il reconnaît
l'état canadien comme étant l'état qui a
pris possession des terres autochtones
possession du droit que les communautés
on est porte depuis le début de la
colonisation d'ailleurs la mouvance
hashtag l'inde bac est la ndp aussi que
les bacs veut que l'on redonne les
terres aux communautés autochtones on
redonne les droits et ça c'est certain
que c'est une mouvance extrêmement
puissant moi je fais partie peut-être un
peu plus de la mouvance qui le languedoc
j'aime beaucoup l'idée je suis
d'ailleurs quand même j'ai quand même
été très impliqué avec hayden moment et
on parle de souveraineté autochtone du
droit de la parole aux actes au nom du
droit de la prise de parole dans les
médias et sur les plates formes
politiques cependant
tout aider l'egypte autour du goût est
plus difficile pour moi d'embarquer
parce que j'ai toujours dit je prendrai
même le stylo de stephen harper pour
pouvoir aller voter contre city venant
tant à l'époque
puisqu'il était problématique mais
justement le vote autochtone la prise de
parole autochtone fait transformer le
milieu politique canadien est donc en
utilisant cet outil là justement on peut
amener de plus en plus la conversation
vers le lendemain vers justement les
droits des communautés autochtones droit
aussi à l'autodétermination des
communautés autochtones et on a de plus
en plus de personnes qui vont en
politique qui sont d'origine autochtone
et le sait le whisky aussi comme par les
autres chroniques du passé je vous
expliquer pourquoi certaines personnes
étaient contentes que comme des
personnes des communautés se présente
aux élections et pourquoi d'autres ne
l'étaient pas cependant moi j'y vais
avec la temporalité de l'état canadien
avec les urgences climatiques avec le
manque d'eau dans les communautés alors
vous comprendrez que quand je vais au
scrutin même si mon idéologie politique
est beaucoup plus basé dans une
présence traditionnelle des membres
d'ailleurs une participation beaucoup
plus actif est beaucoup plus
représentative des communautés
autochtones
je vais dans le moment où je suis dans
la situation dans laquelle je suis voté
pour la situation s'améliore et par le
passé l'augmentation des membres
autochtone dans les milieux politiques
l'augmentation site du vote autochtone
sommes vraiment transformé le paysage
politique canadien et j'utilise beaucoup
dernièrement la force du vote autochtone
comme la comme la preuve que ça peut
transformer un pays -la j'utilise
l'exemple des états unis et où aussi que
le vote autochtone a fait basculer le
paysage politique américain donc je
comprends totalement
l'idéologie du je ne voterai pas pour ne
pas reconnaître parce que ça fait partie
vraiment
d'une manière que le canada ou aussi
éteint les droits docteur donc par la
simulation fait disparaître les droits
et en refusant de voter eh bien on
augmente justement la force de
l'existence des droits la non
disparition les droits autochtones mais
je suis aussi de celles qui disent avec
avec le droit de vote j'ai des droits je
veux que vous me cloutier je veux que
vous reconnaissiez la souveraineté et ça
c'est ma manière de pouvoir le faire
donc c'est pour ça que le vote et le
non-vote deviennent quand même des
débats pendant justement les débats
électorale mais ça devient aussi des
outils qui peuvent être très utiles aux
communautés donc j'invite les gens qui
le veulent qui justement veulent
transformer le paysage politique à aller
voter j'invite aussi ceux qui le veulent
pas voter a continué leur travail parce
qu'il transforme constamment le paysage
politique en étant présent sur les
lignes sur le travail du quotidien pour
justement faire entendre la voix des
communautés autochtones donc on reste
fort et on espère vraiment que nos voix
soient entendues pour ces élections
bonne semaine